avant-hier le juge dit hier le gendarme
aujourd'hui le journaliste les
journalistes mes confrères qui ont
couvert le drame de la vologne en
témoigner au procès villemin témoignages
nécessaires dans la mesure où les médias
ont contribué à l'agitation dans la
mesure où nous avons nous aussi notre
part de responsabilité dominique
verdeilhan eric de lannion dès le 17
octobre 1984 sur les bords de la vologne
il y avait plus de journalistes que
d'enquêteurs isabelle bechler pour
antenne 2 et laurence lacour pour europe
1 était sur place
cette dernière depuis a quitté la presse
par dégoût reconnaît-elle
on a dit beaucoup de choses qui ont dû
salir l'honneur de ces gens là on a vécu
dans le règne de la rumeur c'est vrai
nous nous sommes pris au jeu de la
recherche et laurence lacour de
regretter ce vent de folie ce
défoulement collectif mais de dénoncer
aussi les conférences de presse
quotidiennes des gendarmes un geyser
d'information dit elle et de dénoncer
enfin le fait qu avocats et juges
choisissent est leur interlocuteur dans
la presse si on n'a pas la formation
pour les autres on est à la traîne
et comme on ne pouvait pas vérifier
parce qu'elles soient les autorités
judiciaires
à l'abandon soit les autorités
policières complète ou uniquement pour
alimenter c'est sur cela et michel roux
30 vous pouvez nous faire dire n'importe
quoi
l'arrestation de bernard laroche à son
usine on nous l'a apporté sur un plateau
reconnaît isabelle bechler une ambiance
de lynchage peu propice à la présomption
d'innocence et les deux journalistes de
confesser l'hypothèse christine villemin
était certes la plus folle mais aussi la
plus médiatique est la plus vendeuse
excès de mots excès d'image confesse
aujourd'hui les journalistes qui
regrette cette instruction parallèle
d'être devenus des magistrats par
procuration incompatibilité entre la
logique du fait divers est la logique de
justice
mais tous les journalistes qui se
succèdent à la barre depuis plusieurs
jours rappelle que la presse toutes
tendances confondues a prévenu gendarmes
policiers juge d'instruction des menaces
qu posèrent l'encontre de bernard
laroche
hélas ces mots-là la justice ne les a
pas entendus